protect your bubble calm proud sponsors
of swipe on Sky News you're watching
swipe on the show this we pass the
remote roadside we find out how cars are
getting smarter I take a test drive in a
vehicle that claims to see round corners
and we're leaving the triple A's to one
side as we look at a few standout
independent games in our review this
week remember the days when roads used
to be so quiet so empty no neither do I
and it seems that just as quickly as
roads are getting busier cars are
getting more advanced I mean not so long
ago if you had a sat-nav you might have
been considered a bit of a show-off but
that's not of Hatra some of the bits you
can see in cars these days is well it's
easy to get distracted by the complex
dashboards in modern cars but what if
you could control everything without
having to press any buttons or attempt
to master a glitchy voice control
program
well BMW think they've solved the
problem their gesture control system
lets you do things like adjust your
music make calls or even control cameras
attached to the car simply by waving
your finger in the air gesture control
Francis one of a world-first essentially
for an automotive vehicle and it uses
infrared technology to recognize
different hand movements to operate
features within the car so for instance
if you wanted the volume on the stereo
to go up just move your hand in a
clockwise direction volume down
anti-clockwise you can also control
different camera function movements
accepting reject and telephone calls in
the vehicle and if you're proud of your
parking skills well now you've got some
competition by pressing a button on the
key fob you can maneuver the car into a
space but BMW aren't the only ones
working on remote control vehicles
Mercedes have also added a remote
parking feature to their
eClass and Jaguar Land Rover had created
a prototype Range Rover you can control
using a smartphone at the moment it's
illegal in the UK to remotely operate a
vehicle on public roads but
manufacturers are hoping this will
change so good technology like this
improve the driving experience would you
really want to spend a thousand pounds
two thousand pounds on an expensive key
fob so that just occasionally when you
have a very tight parking spot you're
able to get out of the car I mean
obviously it will be worth doing for the
sort of practical jokes of scaring
people with a remote-controlled feminine
theories but I don't think it will
really take off safety is one of the
most important issues for car makers
this system from Ford uses radar and
cameras to scan the road and warns the
driver if a vehicle or pedestrian is in
the way and if the driver doesn't stop
the car brakes automatically well after
seeing all of that tech we thought we'd
organize our own road safety test
here's Gemma so I've never been in a car
that can see round corners before how is
this going to work and what exactly is
it we've got a split view camera it's
mounted on the front of the vehicle
right and it sits drivers in parking and
manoeuvring yeah well that it's probably
better to demonstrate it in action it's
probably a blind Junction this is pretty
blind up here I'm gonna head towards
this direction
so how does the camera benefit me in a
scenario like this okay
traditionally you would edge so far
forward that you'd be going onto the
footpath or you don't do the line of
traffic what this system does if you
press the button twice before you stick
the bonnet of the car out you're able to
see any obstacles coming from yeah it's
fisheye lens the image processing
stitches the image together so what
feels really alien is that I'm looking
inside the car when I should be looking
left and right really yes and there's a
cyclist step because typically you can
always hear a cyclist coming and I
wouldn't have been able to see him from
back here so if I edged forward a bit
more
because yeah I mean yeah I can see both
Cravens and I still behind the pillar
yep how much is this kit this is a
retailers run about 400 pounds is that
just a bit of an expensive option for a
driver who could just keep on edging out
slowly do you really need it today
people want more and more safety systems
and driver assist features we've gone
from parking aid and rear view cameras
now two people are wanting more advanced
features like this split view camera it
adds a further sense to the vehicle and
they ability to do things that you
wouldn't normally be able to do safely
sales the Commons right we're staying in
the capital but the Victorian Gothic
version with giant crabs that can only
be a reference to our games review but
first is around up of what else has been
going on in the tech world this week
Apple and Samsung are leading the charge
in nominations for this year's t3 Awards
nicknamed the Oscars of tech the Giants
are each up for nine goals including
brand of the year and gadget of the year
the awards take place in September be
careful who you decide to unfriend on
Facebook a new app is letting users
track who is ditching them and when the
free application conveniently named who
deleted me on Facebook breaks down your
friends into categories including new
you deleted deleted you deactivated and
current hash tag orcs forget selfie
sticks here's a way to take hands-free
shot
a phone case with an extraordinary grip
launched on crowdfunding site indiegogo
this week extra verso the Italian
startup behind the case says the
material has a suction effect on flat or
glass surfaces but it isn't sticky
breathe easy single celebrities out
there the popular dating app tinder has
introduced blue ticks for famous and
high-profile users for anyone who
doesn't know the ticks previously seen
on Twitter mean your verified basically
you're the real you so there's no need
to let fame and all that money hold you
back from finding true love
alright I think it's time we took a
break from all that congestion how about
a few games and away from the
blockbuster releases this week we got
Luc Kamali to take us through a few of
his favorite breakthrough indie games
he says you mustn't miss who's raised a
bit of a different one it's set during
the summer of 1994 and what you're
presented with is a series of police
interviews that are filmed with a
real-life actress and she is giving you
bits and pieces of a story
her husband's gone missing and she's
reported him missing but over the course
of these interviews she's somehow become
a suspect
you ever see heard the radio drama
serial it's basically a game version of
that your task is to figure out look
through her alibis look through all the
different bits of evidence she gets is
she guilty
is she not guilty read her body language
she's gives an incredible performance
but there's so much depth to it for a
start you're logged into this computer
system that you're going through this
police database as a guest why you guest
you also get to see partial reflection
of your character in the screen that
becomes clear at certain moments but
less clear at others and all of this
weaves together to create a really
really deep story and as the game of
all's it the payoff at the end is really
really magnificent
it's under-seat your cast as a steamboat
captain in this underwater version of
Victorian London and your task is pretty
simple you need to go out explore all
these islands that are in the underwater
sea but make it back to port safely so
it's all about juggling your resources
supplies your fuel but also your crew
every island you get to will have its
own story kind of like a choose your own
adventure book so you may come to an
island that has loads of walking talking
rats do you make war with them do you
try and give them an offering and that
will then develop the story and what
happens to you next it's a pretty
difficult game so as you explore the
ocean and you find more more things
you're going to want to explore more but
you always need to make it back to port
to refuel because if you don't what
you're going to do are you going to
cannibalize half your crew in order to
keep the rest of them alive but then
it's going to be more difficult don't
have the manpower to get back it's a
great game where the stories are
constantly evolving and updating and
it's incredibly incredibly amazing
sunset is an interesting game yet set
during the 1970s in a fictional South
American country new play an African
American graduate called Angela she's a
cleaner for this very very rich rich man
and their chores in the apartment itself
quite dull they're quite boring but what
you can hear outside is a revolution
going on you can hear sirens gunshots
and for an hour before sunset every day
you're there cleaning and as the story
develops and as you clean most new items
appear in the apartments you know and it
becomes evidence that the man who owns
department is somehow involved in this
resistance and there's also implications
of a relationship between Angela and the
man himself the fantastic thing is
Angela's internal monologues are so well
written and her character is so engaging
that she's definitely someone you'd are
happy to the experience in this story
with but again it's another story that
is just completely moving and emotional
there's it take a look at Scone use the
iPad and mobile for some bonus features
from this week's episode I'll see you
next time bye bye
protect your bubble calm proud sponsors
of swipe on Sky News